We are honoring extraordinary moms all week long.
And one of them is Clarissa Joi.
She had it all, two degrees, a successful career
and a family,
and then all that changed when she got divorced.
And then she quickly turned that fear into confidence
and launched this very successful non-profit called
Rise Up Single Mom,
and it supports countless single moms all over the country.
And Clarissa is here now to talk about it with us.
(audience applauding)
Welcome Clarissa Joi.
Hi Drew, wow, I can't believe I'm here.
I was so excited to talk to you, I'm a single mom
so I was very interested in your story.
What compelled you to help other women not feel alone?
It started with a simple Facebook post,
it was the end of 2016,
and I was looking back over the year and I was so excited
that I was okay as a single mom,
after going through so much darkness
and I just simply wanted to share that with other moms.
And then the responses just poured in,
of other moms thanking me for the post,
and I was like, wow.
Where did this come from?
And then fast forward in 2017
we started the nonprofit organization Rise Up Single Mom.
Is it true that you kept your divorce
a secret from people in the beginning?
Absolutely, I actually even wore my wedding ring
a year after the divorce, simply because
I didn't want to feel like a failure
and I didn't want people to think that I was a failure
and you know, well, how good can she be in other areas
if now her marriage has failed?
Absolutely.
That's it.
If you can't figure out marriage,
then they probably can't figure out anything else.
Absolutely, that's what I was thinking.
That's why I didn't want to share it.
That is one of the most honest, poignant ways
I've gotten to put how divorce feels with another woman.
It's like, you are convinced that others will look at you
as if it has a trickle down effect to everything.
Absolutely, this paranoia just going on in your head,
and despite whether others think that way or not,
it's your reality of how you're feeling inside.
So like what do you say to other mothers
watching right now who are raising their kids on their own
and feeling any of the things we have mentioned?
I would say to other moms it's okay.
There are others that feel exactly as you do
and just as I was there, you also can come from that place,
you will be okay, this is only a season.
You'll get through it.
Clarissa, where were you when I first got divorced?
I'm serious.
Thank goodness that you have been such an inspiration
to so many moms,
and today our virtual audience is filled with single moms.
(audience clapping)
So hello ladies.
I know, how cool is that?
There's actually someone here
who has a special message for you, Tanya, are you there?
Hi Drew, hi Clarissa?
Hi, Tanya, thank you for joining us today.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
Listen, I'm so excited to be here.
Really just thrilled I wanted to say to Clarissa,
thank you so much for founding Rise Up Single Mom.
The first time that I actually met with the organization,
it was a Moms Go Back to School event.
And I remember Clarissa clearly saying
begin with the end in mind, and that always stuck with me.
And I'm here today to say that
we registered for school that day.
I registered for my master's degree
at the University of Memphis.
I have completed all of the classes,
except for one class that starts in July.
And I just want to say thank you Clarissa
for the catalyst that helped me
through those tiny steps to get to my success.
(audience clapping)
So thank you again.
I am so thankful and grateful for this organization.
All the amazing moms in our audience,
we want to celebrate you
by giving you each a hundred dollars gift certificate
to UrbanStems Flowers,
a company that I really, really really love
and Clarissa you're just so inspiring,
and we at the show would love to just give $5,000
towards Rise Up Single Mom
and it's your mission,
it's hard to put into words what you're doing,
but you do wonder if people think you're
incapable of handling other parts of your life,
if you couldn't handle this,
and I just think what you're doing is amazing,
and very necessary.
Wow, I just can't say thank you enough.
This is so truly amazing.
Well, I thank you to our VFFs for coming
and showing up for Clarissa, Tanya
thank you so much,
and go to our website to learn more about Rise Up Single Mom
an organization that I cannot advocate, support
and shine a light on more.
Thank you, Clarissa Joi so much.
(upbeat music)